all right so let's look at this trade
from both sides and Kenny just tell me
what this what this does for the
Clippers now you got kawhai who's 32
Paul George is 33 Westbrook's going to
turn 35 in November 34 year-old James
Harden well he said he was he reunited
with a teammate all the teams he play he
was bound to re reunited with everybody
in the last four years but I I think
this is honestly the best situation for
if we're talking about James Harden
individually first it's the best situ
because I I've said throughout the
summer I think at this stage in his
career he's not a point guard anymore
he's a two guard he he would be better
suited to spot up come off screens
instead of iso at the top and pushing
the pace Russell rushbrook even at 35
we've seen in the you know even in these
three games he's pushes the pace and he
could play at a faster Pace that I think
Paul George and Kawai would need to play
at so I think this is actually better
suited to take him more off the the ball
you know individually secondly the
Clippers were going to contend for an
NBA championship if they're healthy
without James haunted with him what that
gives them I think that's the
flexibility to say if you need to sit
out three games Russell Westbrook you
need to sit out Paul George two three
games you need to sit out Kawai now you
have another scorer that could take the
advantage so they were contending with
or without him this just makes it
possibly a little easier you know for
players of this caliber Kawai PG Russell
and James is Championship
robust uh another big name guy you know
the clippers for the past four or five
years have been very iffy Kenny alluded
to we don't know who's going to be there
who's not going to be there but if this
doesn't if they don't win the
championship it doesn't work yeah they
may win some games they may upset some
teams but players of these Cali
especially guys like Russell and James
they would like to have that
Championship under the belt on paper it
looks good but I don't know which I
don't know which which Harden is going
to show up I don't know which Harden
they want to show up you want to score
and Harden or you want the Harden to you
know be a facil facilitator I'm hearing
all these guys talking on TV about what
option he's going to be and I agree
right now he's the fourth option and
we've never seen a fourth option James
Harden James is the guy that puts it
between his leg controls the ball most
of the shot clock and shoots how are
they going to use them so I have to I
have to well we all have to sit back and
see how it works but if if they don't a
championship it's a bust where's this
put the Clippers in your power ranking
in the Western Conference I don't know
the answer to that question because the
the Russell because your Hat's too tight
well because the Russell Westbrook James
Harden situation is interesting neither
one can play without the ball neither
one can play without the ball now Kenny
had a great point they were going to be
contenders because of Kawai and Paul
George those are the two main guys if
they can stay healthy but I don't know I
know who going to play point guard I
don't know who going to play offg guard
so I don't know how the back court is
going to work but because of Paul and
kaai they're and zubas I love zubas
they're going to be contenders but it's
going to be fascinating because I don't
think either one of those guys can play
without the ball James has been a
dribbler his entire life and Russ has
proven he struggles when he tries to
play off the ball cuz he's not a great
shooter so it's going to be fascinating
watch but I will say James have to get
off the ball I mean the
only spot shoot and he can hold I don't
I don't look at James as a spot shooter
number one he holds the ball and makes
his plays off the dribble but I think
it's a great trade for the Sixers number
one they got rid of the headache they
got it's addition by subtraction yes
number one they bench got better it's
time for Maxi to be the second guy but I
think the biggest beneficiary of this
whole situation is going to be toas
Harris toas Harris is a good player but
you don't get four balls you don't don't
get four balls now he moves to the third
spot you can have three guys who can
score but you can have four guys this
just not a boss not and we'll see what
darl mury does with this all these
pieces that he accumulated in this
deal Ernie there's a reason people gave
you these pieces like everybody just
assume but the draft pieces too I mean
you you got the drop the biggest thing
is the those drop picks ain't going to
be no good but the cap space you know I
think it's $55 million they'll be in the
cap space that sounds good on paper but
they got to pay Maxi got some nice
pieces they got to pay Maxi so so that
that $50 million cuz Maxi going to get a
big deal cuz he deserves it um we are by
the way uh nearing tip off uh there I
can't wait to watch this game tonight we
are 19 minutes and 40 seconds away don't
forget to order your game time favorites
through door dash for tonight's double
header Charles in his head
looks like a custodial engineer Hey
listen don't don't don't mess with
people the golden Bachelor not the
golden
Bachelor oh my goodness gold nothing on
nothing on Jimmy of course not I'm I'm
beautiful you actually wear that pretty
well I know I look good up here want to
consider it thanks bridge I look good
boo boo period